[Musique]
nous allons vous conter l'histoire les
aventures des aventures nous allons vous
conter l'histoire les aventures
ii de monaco
ce jour là
genou
pour lui apprendre actu
2h10
[Musique]
en
ici vous trouverez de quoi passer noël
le ventre plein il suffit de plonger le
saut dans le dos lorsqu'il devient lourd
c'est qu'il est garnie de nourriture
[Musique]
tron
dit comment je dois m'y prendre très
simple comme ceci
conte
comment
à présent attendez une heure ou deux
vous ne tarderez pas à sentir le saut se
remplir de poisson j'aurai la patience
d'attendre au nord
[Musique]
mais
oh il me semble que mme haacke
s'alourdit la pêche sera excellente
il ya déjà un beau pas voyons c'est le
moment
on secoure honneur je t'en prie de
poisson quand je ne puis les soulever
vite venez
[Musique]
comment vous êtes encore là prenez vos
poissons et partez voyons je n'ai pas la
force de soulever le saut écoutez ce
sont les chiens qu'on appelle le craint
de ne pouvoir rien faire pour vous
[Musique]
come on